you know with regard to strikes you know
yesterday the government wrote to all
union leaders inviting them in for talks
on Monday you know incredibly value the
important work that our public sector
workers do especially our nurses and we
want to have an honest grown-up
conversation about what's affordable
what's responsible for the country those
invitations have gone out and I'm
hopeful that those meetings can happen
on Monday so we can have a productive
conversation and find a way through this
I fully believe in the Union's role in
our society and the freedom for them to
strike but I also believe that that
should be balanced with the right of
ordinary working people to go about
their lives free from significant
disruption and that's why we're going to
bring forward new laws in common with
countries like France Italy Spain and
others that ensure that we have minimum
levels of safety in critical areas like
fire like ambulance so that even when
strikes are going on you know that your
health will be protected I think that's
entirely reasonable and that's what our
new laws will do